what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder today
we're going to be talking about
a theory that just makes so much sense
that i think we may have discovered
something very
very huge about the loki series and the
tva
now before we get started i'm not really
going to be talking about
too many spoilers for loki in fact if
you've only seen the first episode that
should be enough
but still only minor minor spoilers so
if you haven't even seen the loki series
it's probably okay
and thank you to darkfire heroes for
sponsoring this video more on them in a
bit but in this video i will be talking
about this new theory that involves time
travel the avengers and the tva we'll
also be connecting this to ant-man and
the wasp quantum mania
and talking about the next big bad
villain which i know a lot of people are
excited for because we really haven't
had a big
bad yet the disney plus series so far
have their own villains and they might
come back but they're not really
massive mcu threats they're not the big
bads today we're going to be talking
about a big
bad and how things are about to get
really exciting so let's
dive into it but also if you want to
enter my marvel chair giveaway the link
is in the description or the pink
comment down below
so this theory in essence and at its
core is pretty simple
the base theory is that the tva exists
in the quantum realm
now this may be a shock to some people
but a lot of people may have already
thought about this
if you've already thought about this
stick with me i'm going to lay out all
of the evidence that actually supports
this theory and
my theory as it's been from the very
first episode of loki is that
kang the conqueror is actually in charge
of the tva
and as we get more into this i'll
explain how it makes sense
but first let's start off by talking
about the tva being inside of the
quantum realm
after ant-man and the wasp came out the
director of the film told us to look
closely at a specific scene when janet
van dyne and hank pym were exiting the
quantum realm in their little ship
and we did we looked closely and what we
found was
a little city inside of the quantum
realm now they stated that this was
going to be a very important part
in the future of the mcu however we all
thought it was referring to avengers
in-game
and we were wrong yes the avengers did
use the quantum realm to time travel
however none of them visited a quantum
city
which leads us to believe that obviously
this city since they said it was going
to play an important part in the future
will appear at some point in time in the
mcu then marvel studios announced the
next ant-man film
titled ant-man and the wasp quantum
mania so clearly ant-man and the wasp is
going to deeply explore the quantum
realm
they also announced the villain of the
film is going to be kang the conqueror
played by jonathan magers
but i believe that we've actually
already seen jonathan majors as kang the
conqueror in loki episode 1.
as i've stated a few times already i
believe that kang
is this middle time keeper there's a lot
of artwork that has been done that has
jonathan magers as king and to me this
really really
looks like jonathan majors as kang and
i'm going to stick with my theory that
this is indeed king the conqueror and
i'll finish my video with
my theory on this but we have more
evidence that suggests that the tva
is in the quantum realm but first please
allow me to thank darkfire heroes for
sponsoring today's video
i play a lot of different games on my
phone but to me
darkfire heroes is an rpg that's kind of
a step above everybody
specifically because it's not a weight
your turn rpg
it's actually an incredibly fast paced
game
with a lot of different aspects to it
making it to where practically everybody
can enjoy it
it's different in the fact that you
don't have to wait for your turn it's
real time power aim
each character has their own unique
special ability
when your hero's ability is fully
charged drag it to the specific spot on
the battlefield that you want to use it
on
you can also spin your mana and use
spell cards to aid your heroes as well
the combination of these makes this game
about skill timing and precision
and they keep it exciting with over 50
different characters and spells that you
can unlock what's also really cool about
it is you can join a guild and compete
in tournaments and they also have
monthly live events
making it a game like no other so click
the link down below to download darkfire
heroes today
so i believe that the city that we saw
inside of the quantum realm could be the
tva as we saw in the very first episode
there is a huge
city that is the tva loki claims that
it's not real it's an illusion but then
he claims that
he thought that there was no magic in
the tva and owen wilson's character
mobius says
there isn't implying that this is simply
a very very
advanced civilization and when you have
an organization that can time travel
yes they are definitely way advanced but
i believe this city could be
that city that we saw in ant-man and the
wasp in the quantum realm and here's
some solid evidence to back it up
in ant-man and the wasp janet van dyne
states that the quantum realm
changes you we learned that she was in
there for 30 years but it didn't look
like she really aged that much
then in avengers in game we know that at
the very end of ant-man and the wasp in
the post-credits scene ant-man got stuck
inside of the quantum realm now he was
stuck in there for five years but in
reality to him
inside of the quantum realm it was only
five minutes to him
and when he's speaking to natasha and
steve he explains that
time works differently inside of the
quantum realm
then fast forward to the very first
episode of loki where loki is inside of
the tva
him and mobius go into the elevator
together and he asks mobius how long
he's been in the tva
in which owen wilson's character mobius
says well it depends
time works differently in the tva
how long have you been here i don't know
it's hard to say
you know time passes differently here in
the tva
what does that mean you'll catch up so
mobius basically said the exact same
thing
that ant-man said time works differently
in the quantum realm
time works differently in the tva and as
we've learned from the ant-man movies
space and time
are believed to be irrelevant in the
quantum realm meaning that it could
exist
outside of space and time or outside of
the sacred timeline that the tva
monitors
now we know that the tva exists outside
of space and time that's how they
monitor time so that's even further
evidence suggesting that the tva
that city is in the quantum realm and
could be that city that we saw
then you take into consideration the
fact that the tva actively time travels
to different times
this is exactly what the avengers did
now of course since the tva and the
timekeepers apparently
exist outside of space and time and
actually right time itself we are led to
believe that
this organization the tva is probably
the most
advanced organization inside of the
marvel cinematic universe more advanced
than anything we've ever seen so they
are millions of years ahead
of the avengers as far as technology is
concerned so essentially they have
mastered time travel
a lot better than the avengers did and
they have their devices that they can
use to open portals however just because
they're a little bit more advanced
doesn't mean that they aren't using the
quantum realm as a means of
transportation
they've just harnessed the quantum realm
in a different way now if you consider
the fact that ant-man and the wasp
showed this quantum city in the past and
if you consider the fact that the next
movie is going to be titled quantomania
where kang is the main villain
we can definitely see how they are
setting all of this up
they've been preparing for kang for a
pretty long time now kang the conqueror
is the master of time travel
there are many different versions of him
most of them are bad but some of them
are good like iron lad but he has
traveled to
millions of different timelines he
basically controls time and a theory
that we had
right after avengers end game is that
kang wasn't going to be too happy about
the avengers traveling through time it
could have messed some things up for him
but
what have we learned from loki it is the
tva
that determines who messes up time
specifically judge rinslayer who works
for the timekeepers however in the
comics
ravona renslayer is the love of king the
conqueror
so if you combine that with the fact
that one of the time keepers actually
looks like kang
you can see how it looks like kang might
actually be in charge of the tva
perhaps there are really no time keepers
at all perhaps this is just a trick
that kang is doing so he can control all
of the timeline and make it whatever he
wants it to be
this would obviously make him a huge
villain a villain who has the power to
literally do whatever he wants he could
write the future
and i believe that kang may have created
the tva as sort of a police for the
timeline
while he rewrites the future and makes
it whatever he wants it to be
now will all of this be revealed in the
loki series i'm not so sure
i do think that if they don't reveal
kang they are going to severely hint at
it
after all we do know he's coming in
ant-man on the wasp quantomania so it
wouldn't really be that big of a
surprise
so if he is behind everything i don't
see why they wouldn't do it
now will they reveal that the tva is
actually in the quantum realm and could
be that quantum city
i'm not sure the city could also be
chronopolis where king lives but there's
no reason why the tva
couldn't be inside of chronopolis itself
but either way i do
believe that the tva is in the quantum
realm and i do believe that
kang is that one time keeper and is in
charge of the tva as well but
we'll have to see let me know what you
think about this theory in the comments
down below
do you think i'm right you think i could
be wrong either way it's a lot of fun to
think about
don't forget to like this video and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof